voici à vincent van gogh est arrivé il y
à 101 ans à la recherche d'une qualité
de lumière et cet artiste méconnu ignoré
et d'invoquer aujourd'hui dans les
vitrines et sur les murs de la ville
comme un enfant du pays
parmi d'autres oeuvres le portrait du
docteur ray relégué 20 ans dans un
poulailler
aujourd'hui prêté par le musée pouchkine
de moscou vient la vedette de
l'exposition qui durera jusqu'au 15 mai
nouvel espace parole
karl est une ville du delta une ville
qui a l'habitude de recevoir des gens
est un lieu de rencontre et une ville
romaine vous savez quand on était
citoyen romain ce n'était pas de
naissance était une dignité
donc à partir du moment où quelqu'un
s'est distingué dans la ville d'arlon et
arlésiens c'était un marlésien des
faubourgs populaires
hors les murs il allait à pied jusqu'à
ses paysages plus que son angle il
cherchait sa lumière pour faire
comme il va
qualité
il a continué à présenter
a poussé l'onu